foreign
October the January 6 committee issued a
subpoena to Donald Trump seeking access
to various records from his time in the
white house now this was a clear
violation of the principle of separation
of powers and it was done for political
reasons so hermit Dillon filed a lawsuit
against the January 6 committee to
contest The subpoena and this week the
committee backed down and withdrew that
subpoena hermit Dillon is the head of
Dylan Law Group she's also running to be
chair of the RNC harmeet thank you so
much for being here I wonder if you
could just start off with a little bit
of context for those at home who wonder
what was the big deal about this
subpoena why did it warrant a lawsuit
and why is it important for the country
that you prevailed in this lawsuit
well thank you for asking Tulsi so this
January 6 committee as we all know has
been going on for a year and a half and
it I would call it an extended
advertisement uh with uh with no actual
legal significance but all political by
the January 6th committee and the
Democrats they pretty much used it as a
commercial for their own side for the
midterm election so now the only
correct purpose of a house Select
Committee investigation is really
towards legislation and in this case the
one piece of legislation that came out
of the January 6 committee was passed in
September having to do with the
Electoral count act and so after that is
when they issued the subpoena for Donald
Trump and sought extensive records I
mean to the point it probably would have
been hundreds of thousands of documents
from his presidency and so the reason
why we fought back is really just stand
for the principle of separation of
powers and this is not the first time
that a president or former president has
been subpoenaed by the house and it
would have been the first time that one
actually testified if he had gone
forward and had not quashed the subpoena
in fact President Truman many years ago
was also subpoenaed after he left office
and he very clearly articulated the same
principles that we did in our lawsuit so
in addition to being over Broad in
addition to being vague in addition to
not pursuing a proper legislative
purpose we articulated separation of
powers issues and we filed that lawsuit
in Florida where president Trump lives
and you know some people are saying oh
Harmony they just let the clock run out
you know that it's no big deal but
actually if the house wanted to fight
our lawsuit they could have immediately
stepped up they were served promptly
they could have stepped up and engaged
with us and had a Court ruling on the
issue they did not want a Court ruling
on the issue they knew they were wrong
they knew they were likely to lose and
as a result they never fought Us in
court and you know they had to back down
yesterday so we're very pleased with the
results for the office of the presidency
and for the concept of separation of
powers
yeah her mate that their reaction
response literally proves your point
right that this was about uh political
moves before the election it was about
posturing and it was about continuing to
show their own political objectives that
they were uh pursuing knowing that it
was a futile effort uh from the
beginning thank you so much for your
expertise expertise and your leadership
and voice on this and so many other
issues
thank you Tulsi
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight